brought to you by rise of the Tomb
Raider 20 year celebration now available
on ps4 so far this year we've been
treated to the heroic stylings of female
protagonists like Zoe Castillo jewel
Adams faith connors and Lara Croft since
we're sponsored by tomb raider this week
I figured we take a look at the female
protagonists who are heading your way
over the rest of the year
a high-flying blond amnesiac cat is
returning in early December of this year
for gravity rush to in the first gravity
rush cat would routinely zip around her
new home of hexa Ville helping those in
need and happily filling the role of
superhero of course that's easy when
you're able to manipulate gravity in any
direction and at any speed in gravity
rush to we're expecting cat to return
with new powers or the environment and
its inhabitants are slated to be far
more lively giving our favorite gravity
Queen plenty of places to traverse and
plenty of people to help out we may not
know her name yet but we do know that
the horse riding bedouin warrior from
battlefield ones trailer will be
playable in the single-player when the
game goes live on October 21 the mystery
woman is a rebel who serves as the right
hand of Lawrence of Arabia you'll step
into her shoes for the war story called
nothing is written where you'll need to
venture through the deserts of the
Middle East and secure weapons and
supplies from the oppressive Ottoman
Empire you'll need to take on the
technologically superior enemy and their
fierce artillery using your rifle and
the advantages to be gained from
attacking on horseback you'll likely be
shooting up the place in battlefield one
but if you feel like changing gears to
be slightly less combat focused kick ass
female lead Kate Walker is coming back
for Siberia 3 while Siberia is one of my
favorite adventure games this little
French series from the early 2000s may
not be on everybody's radar it's a
beautiful story about a lawyer who
abandons her old life and finds herself
trekking across the frozen wastes of
Russia with an optimal matan companion
to fulfill a dying man's final wish
although it's migrating to real-time 3d
graphics Siberia is one of the few point
and click games still around so to see
it's on the fearless kate walker
resurfaced after 12 years it's really
really exciting now I'm sure dishonored
fans will agree that there's nothing
wrong with korver but having played some
pre-release Dishonored 2 I can tell you
that Emily cauldron is some next-level
awesome not only is Emily all grown up
and totally playable in Dishonored 2 she
also has a whole bunch of powers that
are completely independent from her dads
and
good lord they are fun Emily now serves
as Empress of the Isles but when she
suddenly do throned by an otherworldly
usurper it's up to her or Corvo to
travel to kanaka and sort it out The
Outsider has imbued Emily with a host of
supernatural powers including the Domino
ability which chains enemies together so
they all meet the same fate the grapple
like far reach which can be used for
traversal and combat and shadow walk
which transforms her into a dark smoke
like state she's also formidable with
her gadgets so whether you choose to
take on your foes lethally or
non-lethally I'm betting the Empress
will get the job done she might be the
littlest lady on this list but
thirteen-year-old clementine may also be
the fiercest and most battle-hardened we
first met clementine when we were
playing izle Intel tells original
Walking Dead game after losing her
parents little one hid out in her tree
house with a radio as things turned to
go in the zombie apocalypse events went
from bad to worse but through all the
heartache and last we watch Clementine
grow from a terrified kid in a horrible
situation to a strong intelligent
resourceful and commanding young woman
oh you picked all the choices they made
her an [ __ ] it's telltale so your
choice at the end of this year will be
reintroduced to Clementine sometime
after the nasty series of events of
season two that saw her fighting for
survival and desperately trying to say
for friends Clem's been through a hell
of a lot and we've gone from caring for
her to knowing she's tough enough to
handle the zombie apocalypse on her own
let me know who your favorite female
protagonists have been from this year
and beyond and I will catch you again
soon
you